[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
happy Tuesday everyone
so are there any big stories out today
that could change the future of this
country
no good good good
in that case I'd like to talk about
something that concerns me young people
by now you've seen the stats 98 of young
people think I'm hot
I know I know the other two percent were
either born without the gift of sight or
wouldn't know hot if they sat bare ass
on a George Foreman grill
but also there's this when it comes to
the under 30 crowd 63 are single but
just a few years ago in 2019 it was only
51 that's a legitimate jump nine percent
if you will in just a short time
the reasons of course have much to do
with pornography video games and other
apps that made Human Resources seize my
iPad
and certainly the metoo movement played
a role it's easier to avoid intimate
connections altogether than risk being
accused of God knows what so what you're
left with is a dating pool so shallow
even Dana Perino couldn't drown in it
because she's short
but it seems It's just that young people
having problems everyone else is fine
but you know it's not just because we're
already married it's because we're
already older we made it through the
dating game before wokeism hit and
wokeism is like a personality STD
you know what that stands for
me it's killed more sex drives than a
woman of the view swimsuit calendar
for it kills dating by emasculating men
who fear of upsetting women who pretend
to want wokeness when they really don't
what we truly know is that women don't
want a pushover and wokeness is being a
pushover on steroids and not the fun
kind it's the kind they gave Grandma to
treat her rheumatism
wokism fails men because it makes them
look backward not forward to disown your
past instead of anticipate and get
psyched for the future and there's
nothing sexy about a man weeping over
his white privilege it's why men hate
therapy look ahead not back after all
there's a reason boys pick science
fiction over Jane Austen and there's a
reason Elon Musk is more interesting
than Seth Meyers
for one who is Seth Meyers
I've got to ask my writers this Elon is
a perfect example of looking ahead and
Don't Look Back The Men Who do the
reverse become speed bumps in your road
to success so do woke men exist beyond
the media I said it before the only woke
men were successful before they were
awoke hell even Admiral Levine was
Pennsylvania's Health secretary before
he turned in his pants for a girdle
now he's a sheep just so you know
we've seen the toll it takes on the rest
he used to host something called The Man
Show it was crude and funny but today if
his estrogen levels were any higher he'd
be lactating
think about the few successful dudes who
spew woke BS now a decade ago were they
saying that crap back then no they were
trying to be successful and you can't do
that with a woke mindset this is true in
Romance as well and this has girls
wondering where the hell are the men
they've become soft sad and ashamed that
they have testicles
unless of course they're under a dress
women see a dude and a futurist female
t-shirt and it makes them drier than
Nancy Pelosi hiking through the Mojave
Desert
men confused I thought you wanted this
new improved mail well while it was new
it wasn't improved it was a degradation
of Manliness chemical free castration if
you will so women are stuck with what
their gender Warriors ask for a
generation of guys who couldn't change a
tire or enjoy a beer that doesn't have
hints of pumpkin spice in it
women might go to a protest with a woke
agitator but end up attracted to the cop
that's because the cop never made them
wonder is this your bra or mine
so they're skipping the generation of
men altogether for something else and
who's that
old fart yeah a guy who needs Viagra
more than he needs Adderall and the
stats back it up one recent study found
that women in their 20s match with
people the farthest out from their age
range and not just men named DiCaprio
56 of women prefer dating older men and
why do you think that is of course it
could be the maturity or it could just
be the wealth but if you're a 25 year
old woman would you prefer a 25 year old
male who spends his time trying to
cancel other people online or an older
guy who looks out for himself let me put
it another way would you prefer a guy
who spanks it all day or a guy who
spanks you all night
arable yeah they're disgusting somewhere
there's a 25 year old woman watching
this and saying Greg you've just
described my whole approach to dating
hopefully her name isn't Frank and she
doesn't have a penis
but in short an ideal man's priorities
aren't about getting his pronouns right
it's getting his purpose right you can't
do both men can't be woke and be men so
this is good news for Young Smart single
men who have plans love to work lift
weights and eat steak you're in short
supply making you in high demand and if
you disagree with me find a gender
neutral bathroom and cry cry alone
all right so welcome
tonight's guests good thing he's a
doctor because he's got one hell of a
sick body host of asked Dr Drew Dr Drew
Pinsky
he's here cause he thought Dr Drew could
get him penicillin comedian and co-host
of the Jim Norton and Sam Roberts show
us except Jim Norton
after 30 years in TV she describes
tonight's show as you guessed it a low
Point former new Fox News anchor author
of the book write your own story Patty
Ann Brown
[Applause]
she's like a cold Cold Spring day 38 in
Chile Fox News contributor Kat temp
yes uh Jim first congratulations on uh
being voted by GQ uh most woke comedian
it's quite an honor
don't you love that oh the finger
snapping oh I hate when a crowd laughs
or claps
yes yes yes what do you do you agree
with what my theory do you think I'm
hyper hyperbolic or is there some truth
to it I think both I think there is
truth to it but women like it when you
can connect as well like you know what I
mean like they don't just want to you
know every woman doesn't necessarily
want a fireman like they like the fact
that I'm hard as nails but I also cry
when I can't maintain my erection kind
of like a combination of those things
yes yes so I think you're right that
it's not necessarily a sexy quality and
they like older men
um but probably for the same reasons you
said because we have money that's why
yeah or they just think it's sexy when I
tell them how much things cost when I
was their age yes that is definitely a
turn on bab uh uh when you were single
or imagine if you were single would you
have dated a wokester uh what would be
the requirements for that I I don't care
what the requirements are I would not
date a walkster and that's why I was
single for a really really long time but
at the end of the day I ended up
marrying someone younger that's right
um but it's hard to find someone out
there these days yeah like who who's it
hard for well
I listen to this show have you been
looking PAB not lately uh married almost
20 years now and
fully to my younger man but um you
thank you thank you that's what you call
a smattering it's a mattering of a plot
so sure definitely not so sure
um that was polite Applause yes yes I
figured that out
um there's a radio uh segment on this
local radio station called blown off and
I'm addicted to it and it's just a guy
or a girl calls in and says you know I
went on one date or I've dated somebody
for several months and now they blew me
off and I don't know why and they get
the person on the phone and it's always
something really obvious yeah that the
person somehow didn't realize because I
think one of the big problems is that
people don't know how to interact in
person anymore they don't know how to go
on a date they do obviously stupid
things because they get their social
norms from reality TV and social media
and Tick Tock and they have no idea how
to behave in public that's a great point
that is a great point they're
inarticulate and because they're better
used to just dealing in an abstract
environment like online it probably is
Dr Drew's fault right because you've
exploited reality TV oh I'm kidding
report as well taken but I'll tell you
what I've been talking to young people
for decades right so I sort of hear
things before they get into the sort of
data sets and um again this is all very
anecdotal but what I'm hearing lately is
a they're definitely the wind is out of
the sails they're involved with their
pornography and yeah B they're afraid of
being seen as predatory relationships
are hard they have no practice and
working on them and navigating them
they'd rather just sit with their porn
and I'm starting to hear about
prostitution use first time in my career
I'm hearing young man report
spontaneously that this is something
they're doing so that's a transaction
that they can trust because when money
passes hands it's implicit it's
implicitly trustworthy they're not going
to get accused of anything yeah it's
very sad and we really need to encourage
people to meet in flesh in person just
the the healthiness of spending time
with other humans has been lost by
social media so there's a lot going on
and it's I I'm arguing it's a choice
these young men are pulling away I it's
not just the porn is taking the wind out
of the sails they're choosing because
it's if they don't know how to navigate
relationships maybe this is an evolution
maybe this is a positive thing maybe
this whole Adam and Eve stuff was just a
waste of time right now
it's easier to you know if you feel like
that dopamine drip you get from porn
like when you're zoned out in front of
the computer watching porn you can just
kind of give yourself that drug for
hours that's right and a date you get
dinner and all that nonsense I mean more
expensive too more expensive yeah and
and it's uh you know it's just easier to
give yourself that drug yeah
prostitution uh yeah that definitely is
something I'm surprised that young
people haven't talked to you about that
but if you like to hear an older guy
talk to you about it I can here we are
I'm surprised you would need to pay for
sex Jim uh you've never seen me nude
Greg
I don't think it's a surprise cat before
you were married and you're happily
married you dated a lot of losers
I mean not a joke yeah we could go
through we could we'd spend hours
discussing the amount of dirt bags and
no good failures she and I have yeah
that's true yeah I think this is a dude
do you think that Dr Drew is making a
good point on about this these other
things or is it really they just can't
communicate maybe I mean I didn't need
to marry an old man to pay my bills
because I pay for my own bills myself
with my money that I got from building a
fan base of old men
[Laughter]
that's beautiful and I love you I love
you guys don't you yes you I'm talking
about you oh did you forget it you're
gonna say what you're talking about no
matter what your wife says
um I am talking to them
uh I think that there's something to
what you're saying too because my
husband is by far the most conservative
man that I ever dated and he's more
conservative than I am and I I like went
through with it I married him yeah so I
I didn't know that that's what I was
looking for but apparently I must have
been yep there you go there's your
answer that's science right
yes yes do you think dating apps play a
role of course and but here's what
dating app show is that 10 of the people
are having lots of sex and nobody
everyone's else is s out of luck exactly
exactly they it's they go to the same
like top ten percent or five percent
yeah I've done poorly on dating apps
um what I I know because I show up
they're like that's not your picture I'm
like so what I'm funny
the problem with the dating apps is it
eliminates the possibility for somebody
with an interesting personality to
convince a woman that you're worth
taking a risk on even though you don't
look like you know me and it makes
everybody disposable yeah everybody's
disposed how many people start out like
oh my God I hated their guts at first
and then we got to know each other and
then like we we started dating and now
we're married as opposed to I saw this
person they said one thing I had a woman
tell me once since she was a vegan I
went oh do you eat fish she blocked me
[Laughter]
that's awesome
that's fantastic yeah hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else